so first things first I want to get very
very clear that Logan Paul is absolutely
not really a tool of the Matrix he's a
bought and sold individual with no soul
he doesn't stand up for anything and he
doesn't mean anything he says he gets
pieces of paper from Susan or whoever
else telling him what he's allowed to
say on his channel to retain you believe
that 100 not only do I believe that he's
proved himself he will flip-flop on any
issue he can be bought and sold the dude
Logan Paul is a and I will say that here
publicly if anyone wants I'll fight him
for free the guy's an idiot no money
needed nobody knows Logan Paul doesn't
believe in any of the things he says
Logan Paul is a man if you ever were
unfortunate enough to consume his
content I get sent clips of it all the
time by people mocking him as soon as
something comes out whether Harry Styles
wearing a dress whether it's uh little
Naz twerking on the devil whether it's
this he just sits there and goes yeah
this is great yeah this is great he is a
talking piece he is the mouthpiece for
the agenda